if you could have anyone in history on  plug talk who would you pick oh for sure  we're including the dead right  audrey hepburn  audrey hepburn  monroe so it's funny that you went there  too yeah you want to experience some of  that classic [ __ ] that there's like  nobody on record even like rating or  evaluating it right well you know what  nancy reagan after that yeah was she hot  apparently nancy reagan is what they  call the throat goat of hollywood back  in the day she really sucked everybody's  dick and was like the queen i want that  monica lewinsky top too and i want to  see bill before he dies so i can i could  be like hey bro me and you